seesee amazes coming up and we're very
excited because this kind of thing we
don't know what we're going to get up
there and I don't even okay how excited
are you to be up there hosting it's fun
it's gonna be a lot of fun it's gonna be
musical energy and most most of all fan
participation mm-hmm
recently I was at the BT Awards they
kept that show moving it was all about
the audience and energy and I'd like to
bring that energy and that type of
feeling and it felt like a party it was
a celebration not only of the people
winning their awards and who wanted who
lost it was it really about that it was
more celebration of music and it was a
beautiful thing and I'd like to see that
happen here and it's really about the
performances certainly an award show
yeah about the music the artists and you
know the fans most importantly I think
yeah and you're working with Dallas
Smith I know is he incredible and what
ya kinds up for for awards he definitely
is I don't know how he's even gonna have
time to host he's gonna be it's gonna
hell on trapeze around so how do you
work on I mean chemistry with people you
know you guys just met a little bit ago
I heard how do you do is you go through
run throughs and you just sort of pick
off each other or how does that work for
you what's your process my process is
always the same I play everything by
here and about whatever it feels and
there really isn't a process for me to
be honest it's just be real and honest
and truthful and when I meet someone how
it feels and with Dallas he was just a
natural man like it felt pretty good
like right off the bat soon as he said
he was an Olympic bowler
that's my god I said this is the guy
I've been waiting on his energy he's
quick he's smart he's sharp and he's
nominated for four awards he's doing
something right now I think that they
couldn't have picked better this is
going to be a very end
night oh thank you yeah it'll be great
you've had an incredible year I mean
you're played in my home consistently
with Old Town Road my daughter has done
an interpretive dance to your song Oh
which is I can show you later it's all
connects
it's question six oh yeah that's it I
will show you how because your thing
that song has just I mean you're no
stranger to hits obviously that song has
done something really special could you
have ever predicted something like that
and what does it feel like it's it's
just a special song at a special time
the world needed a song to bring people
together you mentioned your six-year-old
daughter or it might be any member of
the family that might have some common
ground in this song whether it's singing
it for the fun of it or just dancing
it's a great dance song and but it's a
bridge of a it's a common denominator
for people around the world and I have
seen that before and I love that feeling
I love seeing people celebrate music and
dance and sing together and you know it
it's kind of what music is supposed to
do yeah and most people only get one of
those in their lifetime and you've had a
few amazing that you're the fabric of
people's lives which is something else
it's kind of shocking to me to be honest
I mean you know hey thank you breaking
heart came out in 1992
you know it's 1982 go ten years before
that and I was playing in a little bar
called changes in Ironton Ohio and one
night after it closed it burnt to the
ground and I just recently opened up for
George Jones and I thought man I'm
almost there I'm almost there well
almost became another year in another
year and pretty soon that time period
became a deck
and that decade was actually full of
many many more failures than successes
success is the progressive realisation
of a worthy idea or gold and I felt way
more times than I succeeded but thank
goodness my dad taught me about
persistence and persistence as to the
quality of the character of man want
carbon is to steal mm-hmm it's not the
force of a jackhammer
that breaks the concrete and you just
keep on keeping on you get knocked down
you get back up that's just the way life
is and you approach it as you know the
the rule is life ain't fair you get you
know you just got to approach it that
way it's a lot be fair you get knocked
down you get back up and that's what you
do well speaking of which I mean I think
this song little nas axe came out and
talking about being knocked down there
were some really nasty awful things
being said how did that affect you I've
heard nothing but great things said
about little nas because he's just such
a great man and he said he's I'm telling
you man when I'm dead and gone people
will be talking about little nas being
one of the great thinkers of our time
like they talk about Thomas Edison er
norman vincent peale little nas ex was a
young man that studied his field and
though he had never played a live show
more importantly what he did do was look
into what makes music be able to go
around the world without a major record
company without a million dollars
without a promoter yeah he studied it
and knew the rhythms of what was going
on in everyone's phones and computers
and what to me that's genius yeah I must
I'm in the business and a student of the
business but I didn't know what tick
tock was when I heard Old Town Road I
was introduced to tick tock at the
very same second that I heard Old Town
Road and I got this message that little
NAS was trying to get the song to me to
hear it and I went to saw this thing on
tick tock
I listened to it I loved it it's a hit
you're in I didn't know what I could do
for it to be honest I answered back and
said you know thank you for thinking of
me but I'd really don't know what I
could do to add to this it's already a
monster smash there's nothing I could do
to it but mess it up oh but I just
thought it was a hit to be honest I just
thought it was a hit and that like less
is always more in music I'm you don't
need me and it don't need another versus
a hit but he asked about I know and I
thought you know if he thinks I can help
him in any way I want to do that and I'm
glad I did I really am
yeah you're in all of our homes all the
time and you've got Chevy's and fourth
the new single talked a little bit about
that one well Chevy's and Ford's is a
great country song that I'm singing with
Johnny McGuire it's a great artist he
got a very unique voice a very unique
talent this or this is a really cool guy
that sings great country music and
writes great country songs and I'm a fan
of that I mentioned George Jones or
Waylon Jennings Willie Nelson I'm a fan
of great country music singers and great
great country music songs and when I
heard Chevy some boards I like I want
that sounds I love it yes so that's kind
of what I'm doing right now is just if
something feels good I go with this and
if it doesn't I stay away from
you